i've had this bad for over six years
six years and it still looks like this
it's holding up very well
it's like a tesla it's like the tesla of
luggage
i swear what's up g46 at nasa this is
[Music]
this is a diabetic kit for myself
which basically helps me find out what
my blood sugar is
then i'm type 1 diabetic i cannot
live without this i mean before i was
definitely like
extremely scary but i think now i just
sort of look at it like a
healthy diet you know like i just have
to eat that you know
that's people who should be good anyway
so all right
this thing is my comedy song
wallet wallet which i pretty much
carry everywhere i go i don't know what
i would do without it carries my credit
card
very very essential i just found kind of
like
shopping at dover street i had another
one and i was like uh
maybe black is better yeah and i got
this one i've been in love with it ever
since
oh my buddy the good old passport
yeah this is this allows me to travel
the world
and go to london to shop at double
street marketing
obviously i really love europe i haven't
really been to any highlands or anything
like that yet
am i kidding i can live anywhere in the
world just be anywhere
just love the city in the city about me
back i'm actually pretty handsome on my
passport
might just my hairline was a little
these are my headphones
which i need everywhere i even use
headphones pretty much
every day to be honest not these ones in
particular these are more of my like
travel headphones i can't hear myself
think when i put these things on and
then they're
very loud you know if i get an uber at
some time i'm actually not listening to
music i might just be on my phone and
like
yeah like i'll definitely just have my
headphones in and like act like i'm
listening to music so they won't talk to
me
this is a pair of socks
which usually i keep a pair of these
in my travel bag or my luggage or
on my feet i love them they're very
narrow and like thin they're like dress
socks almost
showing the sock can be very very really
nice i didn't do my laundry for a while
so like
people who did do it their glue shops
like i'm still
looking for a pair that i have that like
wouldn't miss it i don't know if it's
here somewhere
just floss i don't know this
is my keys to tour my mercedes
this is to my black one
which is currently in the hospital i
call it a car shop the hospital for my
cars
this particular car i gave to except for
someone i wish i would have never done
that
so after that one i got another one
which is white really classy and
tasteful
that's how i like to drive so these
are a pair of comb trousers and um
yeah it's one of my favorite pairs of
pen trousers every
wacko they're very very nice they're
cozy
pretty straight leg but they sit very
very nicely on top of shoes like about
the way them with these they would look
really really nice
these uh jj only boundaries hello i'm
gonna catch you that's really not gonna
get you i'm gonna catch it
all right this is
my favorite i know a lot of people carry
it get your luggage louis vuitton
yard but this bad boy right here let me
tell you
the best four hundred dollars you can
possibly spend on a luggage
and i'm no consultant or anything from
north face you should probably cut me a
check after this
however this is the best way to travel
you know people spend all this money
they buy a gold yard they follow stuff
you put it under the plane guess what
since they could give a rat test how
much you spend on your luggage
they're going to throw that under the
plane just like they throw every piece
of
trash luggage that goes under there and
it's a waste of money
right so you spend four hundred dollars
and you get this north east travel
luggage if it's
oh boy
everyone out there who's spending
thousands of dollars buying louis
vuitton luggage to travel with it
you should probably just get yourself
your face luggage and
happy little buddy call it a day my next
essential
is i don't know if you can see them from
here
i always wear the ring guy and i like to
make them a lot of
like i'll go to like something like i'm
walking somewhere there's a shopping
district and i'll see like
jewelry or costume jury i'll stop and
just look at the costume jury like
sometime like you know it'll be like
really really great ideas their lives
and like
fake jury like coffee juice i'll see
something that
isn't exactly real and i'm like okay
let's make it not make it
but yeah these are crazy so these
actually i took these from my
ex-girlfriend
i guess they sent them third and yeah
she would never wear them and then like
i was like
yeah i hate roasting and then one day i
don't know what it was about them i just
showed him i got dressed and then like
i saw them laying around and i just put
them on i had like a lacoste like
polo shirt like some trousers and like
some cops caught again i was doing my
little thing that day
and um i just put them on it's like a
navy blue like
lacaze cardigan and that old white um
cospolo like these
i think i had navy trousers like these
lime
green marzella trainers this outfit
sounds crazy but it was actually pretty
fire
know i just put these glasses on and it
just kind of like popped like
one more day and then ever since that
day they've been like my favorite
sunglasses
so to my ex you'll never get these back
they're mine
they're mine all right it's like they're
like replicas of
like the glasses that andy warhor warhol
sorry you know someone would be quick to
correct me he said war
okay
boy